no matter who you are or where you live
I'm guessing that you have at least one
relative that likes to forward those
emails you know the ones I'm talking
about the ones with dubious claims or
conspiracy videos and you've probably
already muted them on Facebook for
sharing social posts like this one it's
an image of a banana with a strange red
cross running through the sensor and the
text around it is warning people not to
eat fruits that look like this
suggesting they've been injected with
blood contaminated with the HIV virus
and the social share message above it
simply says please forward to save lives
now fact checkers have been debunking
this one for years but it's one of those
rumors that just won't die zombie rumor
and of course it's entirely false it
might be tempting to laugh an example
like this to say well who would believe
this anyway but the reason it's a zombie
rumor is because it taps into people's
deepest fears about their own safety and
that's of the people that they love and
if you spend as much time as I have
looking at misinformation you know that
this is just one example of many that
taps into people's deepest fears and
vulnerabilities every day across the
world we see scores of new memes on
Instagram encouraging parents not to
vaccinate their children we see new
videos on YouTube explaining that
climate changes are hoaxes and across
all platforms we see endless posts
designed to demonize others on the basis
of their race religion or sexuality
welcome to one of the central challenges
of our time how can we maintain in
Internet with freedom of expression at
the core while also ensuring that the
content that's being disseminated
doesn't cause irreparable harm to our
democracies our communities and to our
physical and mental well-being because
we live in the information age yet the
central currency upon which we all
depend information is no longer deemed
entirely trustworthy and at times can
appear downright dangerous
this is thanks in part to the runaway
growth of social sharing platforms that
allow us to scroll through where lies
and facts sit side by side but with no
one of the traditional signals of
trustworthiness and goodness our
language around this is horribly muddled
people are still obsessed with the
phrase fake news despite the fact that
extraordinarily unhelpful and use the
describe a number of things they're
actually very different lies rumors
hoaxes conspiracies propaganda and I
really wish we could stop using a phrase
that's been co-opted by politicians
right around the world from the left and
the right used as a weapon to attack a
free and independent press because we
need our professional news media now
more than ever and besides most of this
content doesn't even masquerade as news
its memes videos social posts and most
of it is not fake it's misleading we
tend to fixate on what's true or false
but the biggest concern is actually the
weaponization of context because the
most effective disinformation has always
been that which has a kernel of truth to
it let's take this example from London
from March 2017 a tweet that circulated
widely in the aftermath of a terrorist
incident on westminster bridge this is a
genuine image not fake the woman who
appears in the photograph was
interviewed afterwards and she explained
that she was utterly traumatized she was
on the phone to a loved one and she
wasn't looking at the victim out of
respect but it still was circulated
widely with this Islamophobic framing
with multiple hashtags including one ban
islam now if you worked at twitter what
would you do would you take that down or
would you leave it up my gut reaction my
emotional reaction is to take this down
I hate the framing of this image but
freedom of expression is a human right
and if we start taking down speech that
makes us feel uncomfortable we're in
trouble and this might look like a
clear-cut case but actually most speech
isn't these lines are incredibly
difficult to draw
what's a well-meaning decision by one
person is outright censorship to the
next what we now know is that this
account Texas lone Starr was part of a
wider Russian disinformation campaign
one that has since been taken down would
that change your view it would mine
because now is
a coordinated campaign to sow discord
and for those of you who'd like to think
that artificial intelligence will solve
all of our problems I think we can agree
that we're a long way away from AI
that's able to make sense of post like
this so I'd like to explain three
interlocking issues that makes this make
this so complex and then think about
some ways we can consider these
challenges first we just don't have a
rational relationship to information we
have an emotional one it's just not true
them more facts will make everything ok
because the algorithms that determine
what content we see will they're
designed to reward our emotional
responses and when we're fearful over
simplified narratives conspiratorial
explanations and language that demonizes
others is far more effective and besides
many of these companies their business
model is attached to attention which
means these algorithms will always be
skewed towards emotion second most of
the speech I'm talking about here is
legal it would be a different matter if
I was talking about child sexual abuse
imagery or concert that incites violence
it can be perfectly legal to post an
outright lie but people keep talking
about taking down problematic or harmful
content but with no clear definition of
what they mean by that including Mark
Zuckerberg who recently called for
global regulation to moderate speech and
my concern is that we're seeing
governments right around the world
rolling out hasty policy decisions that
might actually trigger much more serious
consequences when it comes to our speech
and even if we could decide which speech
to take up or take down we've never had
so much speech every second millions of
pieces of content are uploaded by people
right around the world in different
languages drawing on thousands of
different cultural contexts we've simply
never had effective mechanisms to
moderate speech at this scale whether
powered by humans or by technology and
third these companies Google Twitter
Facebook whatsapp they're part of a
wider information ecosystem we like to
lay all the blame at their feet but the
truth is the mass media and elected
officials can also play an equal role in
amplifying rumors and conspiracies when
they want to as can
we when we mindlessly forward too busy
for misleading content without trying
we're adding to the pollution I know
we're all looking for an easy fix but
there just isn't one any solution will
have to be rolled out at a massive scale
internet scale and yes the platforms
they're used to operating at that level
but can and should we allow them to fix
these problems they're certainly trying
but most of us would agree that actually
we don't want global corporations to be
the guardians of truth and fairness
online I also think the platforms would
agree with that
and at the moment they're marking their
own homework they like to tell us that
the interventions they're rolling out
are working but because they write their
own transparency reports there's no way
for us to independently verify what's
actually happening and let's also be
clear that most of the changes we see
only happen after journalists undertake
an investigation and find evidence of
bias or content that breaks their
Community Guidelines so yes these
companies have to pay a really important
role in this process but they can't
control it so what about governments
many people believe that global
regulation is our last hope in terms of
cleaning up our information ecosystem
but what I see are lawmakers who are
struggling to keep up-to-date with the
rapid changes in technology and worse
they're working in the dark because they
don't have access to data to understand
what's happening on these platforms in
any way which governments would we trust
to do this we need a global response not
a national one so the missing link is us
it's those people who use these
technologies every day can we design a
new infrastructure to support quality
information well I believe we can and
I've got a few ideas about what we might
be able to actually do so firstly if
we're serious about bringing the public
into this can we take some inspiration
from Wikipedia they've shown us what's
possible yes it's not perfect but
they've demonstrated that with the right
structures with a global outlook and
lots and lots of transparency you can
build something that will earn the trust
of most people because we have to find a
way to tap into
the collective wisdom and experience of
all users this is particularly the case
for women people of color and
underrepresented groups because guess
what they are experts when it comes to
hate and disinformation because they
have been the targets of these campaigns
for so long and over the years they've
been raising flags and they haven't been
listened to this has got to change so
could we build a Wikipedia for trust
could we find a way that users can
actually provide insights they could
offer insights around difficult content
moderation decisions they could provide
feedback when platforms decide that they
want to roll out new changes second
people's experiences with information is
personalized my Facebook newsfeed is
very different to yours your YouTube
recommendations are very different to
mine that makes it impossible for us to
actually examine what information people
are seeing so could we imagine
developing some kind of centralized open
repository for anonymized data with
privacy and ethical concerns built in
because imagine what we would learn if
we built out a global network of
concerned citizens who wanted to donate
their social data to science because we
actually know very little about the
long-term consequences of hate and
disinformation on people's attitudes and
behaviors and what we do know most of
that has been carried out in the u.s.
despite the fact that this is a global
problem we need to work on that too and
third can we find a way to connect the
dots know one sector let alone nonprofit
startup or government is going to solve
this but there are very smart people
right around the world working on these
challenges from newsrooms civil society
academia activist groups and you can see
some of them here some are building out
indicators of content credibility are
there's a fact-checking so that false
claims videos and images can be down
ranked by the platform's a non-profit
they helped to found first draft is
working with normally competitive
newsrooms around the world to help them
build out investigative collaborative
programs and Danny Hillis a software
architect is designing a new system
called the underlay which will be a
record of all public statements of facts
connected to their sources so that
people and algorithms compare to judge
what is credible
and educators around the world are
testing different techniques for finding
ways to make people critical of the
content they consume all of these
efforts are wonderful but they're
working in silos and many of them are
woefully underfunded there are also
hundreds of very smart people working
inside these companies but again these
efforts can feel disjointed because
they're actually developing different
solutions to the same problems how can
we find a way to bring people together
in one physical location for days or
weeks at a time so they can actually
tackle these problems together but from
their different perspectives so can we
do this can we build out a coordinate
and ambitious response one that matches
the scale and the complexity of the
problem I really think we can together
let's rebuild our information Commons
thank you
[Applause]